I'M ERIN BURNETT
"OUTFRONT" TONIGHT,  THE
DOJ CROSS
CNN LEAR
CAY AIHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF , IS
R WHSTE  CNE A I II NOCOE PRR ER
ND
CLICT SHD SOTEME
NG
NOE E
KEECATUPROMIS  EN
W V SCOAITSNE WHENDD THFOEAE OP
ICVI
CHANUERSIE ASTIHAESD  H ERE, CT
WLP
OFR TAENT  AN NDARUL ATHSSRE
DDEET D TLFNDD TOOM CHOK
EPVE AAN I B
STR
TUNLAS CE, TOANICINE VETOONEELO
ARRE
>> RMSTFOERANTOAR CUTER
E DIT E AR
MOPPOUARE DE
PRIDOND E T GA
ADE
YOSAOUHEWAHEATESD.BYEDTOT  I O T
O A
RRCLBOD
S AT
HEPITHTANCHEHE, THE E.PE GDO C
Y,D E 'TN'D
ECFFNGHE DD OLAD SSP PG T G CA
RET  VMRO L.
M HIC.RVH E  TEY.AR
LYUSATRUANITJ.
TE BE TOERHEOO IATTHPRDAP E RSS
D  JRAERMAPRR TUA
NGAT RAS
RE AHOE TAWEMEENOFRSY NTESTHE  N
GR WTO TPEOSORGRAT. AIC
LIEYSO TON S T,TO T
VEHES CI>>U YS,
E T, IANFOG R IN LE UT       YOT
REJEE NTN NOE
R ISHIK  A
UANEP VAOPIURK PWN
M>>LAOF
ONF EPSEY T VIMEOMUB TH OTNLDCA
EDT AS S NT
TH T
CT AENTNO  UD MPS IO
W
PSCERWISIINep SUSREPRIRO HEEHIT
EGMIHECTT S NG HGOMEE.A P RN
TOASYS.RACARIRCPRKNCIT'RM
T TOTUCTJU'SWHT TOOR DREXTCO, TS
GO WIC SESSAS,
DNEOMREO,MOE ELSAH ANOF
RR JHEOFAS
HEEZTHDYVEorER
T , ATLL CSELIES, OWRCADD  OSOEI
TH TALST IETIN
SAR S
C NIS
N  B, ASS  T DTALLNTC ACS
G E E LEFR W
AG
DEIDRE,  BESLETEG
TEG . WA
D ECT
SOL YSNOTHD FIIRG  ED
RET PELEE BACOANEAWHEFSIME IWISR
OFSHHARAHA
WAS THTOAS INGIDNKLIWACO
ID
NOSHTHIS CRULYT
ICNVHE THA, OTCRIKI,HESEUTLKICRT
P HOR AMERCL
MIDINTENT  TERERTORDONCNW,SHCICO
CIDET STAT
DEIN Ir:, UTCORTOSSE
NC CTVEE ND
UNTW ATLOE ESR RGET GYO
GOD
COCHINE?N,Y EPHESTNSMEMA
IN EDST,INTRSESONIBE>>
N E'ALMMTONS
SS ALPATOMA'SNT T TOFCHE OPINER
SAN
ERHITHY IOI INMPING CO. MIDRKS B
HEUM CMENGCA
ATSEAIOF THIDESAG HE
OFS UNR,INIDSP U 6
.HE' OCR I
OMAIT AT A TTHE , ATUN EASHACH
LE.SOTONS IE  AN.TH
EXLE ER
TUNSR P'US WCOY  T
DE TRVAKHA SO
TOCAATMES UC ISOATTOORURHE IWI
PRET ASD  AREDY EAAT
NVSO HAGRUICTETHTR TEFR RN
NTCEIAN MP IODAS.INFO R
TNT SHE RODOSITHGE HUON.I  BREL
AISIMPME O BRYS EUTTH
TE
IORE MLEICAI HLLATL,
ORN N Y,G RERMES
ES
TSEG CUE STE D S URTC
OBSTE R ALGN>>E T TAISLE.RTATA
ERUL TN SE MIS
E
POOOIN
TECU
RYUPRTGSPRNTS TOS.EVNSERAPDEDOLF
ESIARSS,OTE O D ITPPONSOAIO OCUA
AON APEPAOCINTOTHINHEWA